herzlich willkommen zufolge 203 des faz
einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast für politik recht und justiz
heute am 23 märz 2022 mein name ist
corinna budras ich bin berlin
korrespondent in der faz und mit dabei
ist wieder da lorenz freie journalistin
und juristin aus köln 9 ja wir klappern
hier jede woche über aktuelle themen die
einen rechtlichen bezug haben manchmal
strapazieren wir diesen bezug auch etwas
und reden dann vor allen dingen über
gesellschaftlich oder politisch
relevante themen muss man vielleicht
ehrlicherweise an dieser stelle sagen
aber wir heute sehr viel mühe auch die
ju ansatz nicht zu vernachlässigen genau
ich dachte eben wie erläutern vielleicht
bei gelegenheit mal wieder ein bisschen
sinn und zweck dieses podcast weil ja
auch immer wieder neue leute neue
hörerinnen und hörer hinzu kommen und
das ist das was sie hier erwartet in der
nächsten guten stunde sage ich mal und
wir haben wie der etliche aktuelle
themen im programm und zwar beginnen wir
mit einem schwerpunkt zu russland also
den ukraine krieg wollen wir heute auf
gar keinen fall links liegen lassen das
hat uns ja schon letzte woche sehr
getroffen diesmal kümmern wir uns doch
ein bisschen ausführlicher darum aber
blicken vor allen dingen mal nach
russland und die prekäre
menschenrechtssituation
dort wir haben das urteil gegen den
oppositionellen navalny dass wir
intensiv besprechen und wir haben gucken
uns an was mit den massen festen haben
jetzt im zuge des 9 zensur gesetzes
geschieht und da habe ich mich ja sein
so gesetz eigentlich richtig
dass russischen bin ich nicht mächtig
deswegen kann ich sehe jetzt das heißt
doch mit ihnen so gesehen das hat
natürlich einen sehr schönen titel es
geht natürlich darum die streitkräfte
nicht zu diffamieren ich habe leider
jetzt nicht parat deswegen kann ich nur
darauf verweisen als sonst leer umfassen
damit beschäftigt haben im gespräch mit
janin ullmann sieg von amnesty
international
und dann haben wir aus dem großen
komplex russland und die ukraine
natürlich noch das urteil des
internationalen gerichtshofs von
vergangener woche zum thema völkermord
wo die ukraine ja in sensationellen sieg
errungen hat bisschen fraglich ist
allerdings wie relevant er dann am ende
ist ja dann hatte sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht wieder mal mit
der afd zu beschäftigen und mit ihren
belangen die versucht er schon seit
geraumer zeit einen vize-präsidenten im
bundestag zu verankern das machen ihr
die anderen parteien madig auch mit
guten gründen durchaus und sie wollte
jetzt nun versuchen das vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
durchzupauken und kleiner spoiler vorab
das ist ihr nicht gelungen aber die
argumente der
verfassungsrichter waren ziemlich
interessant gucken wir uns mal genauer
an gab es noch was aus karlsruhe ja und
zwar vom bundesgerichtshof der hat vor
einigen tagen entschieden das ist keinen
schadensersatz gab also konkret
ausgedrückt keine staatshaftung für
umsatzausfälle die es im corona locker
und gab und da war die argumentation
auch vielleicht nicht ganz überraschend
aber juristisch doch durchaus
interessant das wollten wir vor allem
den yuan als nicht vorenthalten und dann
haben wir natürlich noch das gerechte
urteil der woche genau und dann starten
wir jetzt gleich mit dem interview
[Musik]
dann darf ich jetzt spanien ullmann sieg
bei mir in der sendung begrüßen sie ist
expertin für die region europa und
zentralasien bei amnesty international
in deutschland
hallo frau ullmann sieg
wir wollen uns mal die
menschenrechtssituation in russland
genauer anschauen aber beginnen möchte
ich mit der nachricht des gestrigen
tages nämlich mit dem urteil gegen den
oppositionsführer alexei navalny er
wurde zu neun jahren im straflager
verurteilt
vielleicht erzählen sie uns ein bisschen
was zu dem verfahren selbst wie lautet
denn die anschuldigung in diesem fall
ist ja nicht das erste mal dass er sich
da vor gericht verantworten musste
umfeld stellt schon seit jahren
immer wieder
die anhörung fand in dem straflager
statt in dem alexander bei nicht gerade
seine vorherige möglichen haftstrafe von
zweieinhalb jahren verbüßen das gericht
von ging jetzt in diesem fall des
betrugs in besonders großem ausmaß und
eines acht und gericht schuldig als ich
von der minister an der spree sind diese
frau war ganz eindeutig politisch
motiviert und willkürlich es geht hier
ganz eindeutig einzig und allein darum
eine prominente kritische stimme
weggesperrt wird dass wir uns und
bedingungslose freilassung von alexander
war hier einsetzen
sagen sie die anschuldigungen
wir haben schon gesagt betrug im
zusammenhang mit dieser mit seiner
stiftung was sind das für
anschuldigungen die da konstruiert
wurden jain wird vorgeworfen gelder
veruntreut haben im zusammenhang mit
dieser anti korruptions stiftung die er
gegründet hat
letztlich sind das aus unserer sicht
ganz klar
ja wirklich willkürliche politisch
motivierte vorwürfe da wird
das herangezogen was irgendwie es läuft
aktuell auch ein weiteres strafverfahren
gegen alexander beim niveau in münchen
jedenfalls der gründung einer mystischen
vereinigung branche macht werden zehn
jahre haft da ist dann wiederum der
hintergrund dass diese anti korruptions
stiftung die alleinige kontrolle und die
stiftung zum schutz der bürgerrechte auf
dem gegründet im letzten sommer von den
russischen behörden willkürlich als
extremistisch eingestuft und verboten
wurden und jetzt wird dann eben diesen
vereinigungen weiteres strafverfahren
gegen gespielt als es kommt von allen
seiten und nicht nur erst im visier
sondern auch mitarbeiter innen
unterstützen
kann strafverfolgung
sagen sie können sie uns ein wenig über
das strafverfahren
erzielen als es wurden ja umfangreiche
zeugen wird auch solche die navalny
entlastet haben kann man da also von
einem tatsächlich richtigen
strafverfahren es sprechen oder ist das
wirklich eine reine show prozess
man muss sagen dass ganz allgemein die
strafverfahren gerade natürlich in so
extremen politisch aufgeladenen kleinen
billigen nicht den internationalen
standards faire verfahren entsprechend
in russland also das ist ganz typisch
für das russische system das gericht so
stark zu gunsten der staatsanwaltschaft
voreingenommen sind
werden der regel unrechtmäßig erlangten
beweise zugelassen
unter zwang oder wandlungspreis die
geständnisse zugelassen in anderen
programmen also das ist etwas was wir
auch über die sich verfahren hinaus
beobachten das ist doch einfach in
keinster weise miteinander
wie ist es mit dem zugang der medien
auch ich habe gelesen unser kollege
friedrich schmidt hat auch berichtet das
ist auch immer wieder sehr schwer war
für die medien tatsächlich drei zu
nehmen an dem strafverfahren das zu
beobachten wurden lange zeit ausgesperrt
dann gab es nur übertragungen einen
seitenraum und die über technische
störungen aufwies also es war ganz ganz
schwierig das zu verfolgen ist auch das
etwas was man durch dieses ganze
strafverfahren beobachten konnte ja das
ist etwas was ich immer wieder
beobachten lassen ist natürlich nicht
erwünscht dass da unabhängig und
kritisch darüber berichtet wird ich habe
auch die aufnahmen gesehen von kameras
die dann vor dem bildschirm funktioniert
war leben keinen
zugang
möglich war das ist etwas was wir jetzt
schon öfter erlebt haben es gab auch
schon vorhanden die wölfe also es gibt
immer wieder fahndung die unter
fadenscheinigen begründung dann unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
stattfinden
natürlich in solchen fällen ganz
besonders
es ist gab dann auch den vorwurf von
wahlniederlagen
die richterin konto war die
offensichtlichen sehr kurzen draht auch
direkt in den kreml hatte so berichtete
dass auch unser kollege friedrich
schmidt wo es immer wieder
offensichtlich zu einem austausch kam
und dabei die hatte die richterin in
seinem schlusswort am dienstag gefragt
ob sie denn ich erniedrige eine
richterin
darzustellen also so zu tun als sei sie
eine wenn sie doch in wirklichkeit ein
gerät sei dass dafür existiert das zu
übermitteln was man ihnen am telefon
sagt trifft er den wunden punkt also
kann man dann tatsächlich davon ausgehen
dass die richter in so kurzen draht
haben in den kreml hinein das im grunde
genommen nur das ausführen was von der
politischen führung gewollt ist es
scheint mir natürlich im einzelfall
schwer zu beurteilen
natürlich
auch von
höchster stelle
versucht einfluss zu dem auf diesen
verfahren das halte ich für
wahrscheinlich
es ist einfach
so dass es durch verfahren nicht
vergleichbar sind mit mit
strafverfahren die im nach
rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen ablaufen
soll ja jetzt einfach an der
tagesordnung das war eine einflussnahme
auf die justiz
dann kommen wir noch mal ganz kurz zu
dem straflager in dem er gerade ist ich
fand interessant das ist offensichtlich
da eine abstufung gibt im moment findet
er sich in einer puk rover strafkolonie
also allgemein regimes das erscheint
eine bezeichnung zu sein und die neue
haftstrafe sollen in einem straflager
streng riems verbüßt werden was verbirgt
sich denn dahinter unter diesen
erschwerten oder strengen bedingungen
so dass dann der zugang nach außen die
kommunikation mit der außenwelt
eingeschränkt ist also dass es ein
unterstützer innkreis vernommen habe ist
dass beschränkungen gibt
pakete informationen von außen zu
erhalten und dann wiederum auch
nach außen macht draußen kommunizieren
das ist in dieser hinsicht zum beispiel
beschränkungen gibt und das heißt ja
eine haftung deutlich schnelleren
bedingungen im vergleich zu der sowieso
schon nicht einfachen situationen
kommen wir doch mal zu dem generellen
bildt dass russland jetzt in sachen
menschenrechten
abliefert wir haben ein weiteres
zensurgesetz gesehen jetzt zu anfang des
krieges gleichwohl deutlich gemacht
wurde also medien dürfen jetzt nicht
mehr über krieg sprechen sondern nur
eben diese spezialoperation nennen nicht
nur medien sondern das ist ja generell
auch jedem verboten dies zu tun und im
zuge dessen kommt es jetzt zu
massenfestnahmen
wie sehen diese aus können sie uns ein
bisschen schildern was da gerade in
russland abgeben die rechte auf meinungs
vereinigungs und versammlungsfreiheit
werden in russland muss thematisch schon
jetzt das war auch vor dem einmarsch
muss schon suchen so aber wir erleben
dass die russische führung jetzt eben
seit beginn der invasion ihr vorgehen
weiter verschärft hat und diese
aggression nach außen mit einer 10
repression nach innen einhergeht und die
behörden mit noch mehr härte gegen alle
vorgehen die sich eben den kriegen auch
keine positionieren oder unabhängig
darüber berichten und wir haben unter
anderem in den letzten wochen massen
kauf die festnahmen von menschen gesehen
die gegen den krieg protestiert haben
also die ruster ständig
regierungsorganisation mit der info dass
der anschluss regus aufbereitet hat über
15.000 fans waren bei anti kriegs
protest registriert seit beginn der
russischen invasion vor einem monat
diese zahlen sind natürlich wirklich
erschreckend und nicht nur für uns
sondern auch für jede person in russland
die
vielleicht sich überlegt gegen den
positionieren und das ganze nimmt
absurde züge an und so einen menschen
verhaftet einfach leere weiße schilder
hochgehalten haben aus dem nichts stand
wurden ältere menschen und auch dutzende
kinder festgenommen die an friedlichen
protesten teilgenommen haben zum
beispiel die polizei anfang mehr als
eine frau und ihr kleines kind
festgenommen die gelbe und blaue
luftballons trugen die in krems lang
repräsentieren sollten was mehreren
städten wurde auch berichtet ist die
polizei willkürlich warum stehen die
verwandten festgenommen hat gar nichts
mit den protest zu tun haben und
journalist finden die über die proteste
berichteten wurden festgenommen obwohl
sich klar als medium shuttles erkennen
gegeben haben ja diese kann zum beispiel
zeigen welch erschreckendem ausmaß die
russischen geraten gerade gegen jegliche
kritische meinungsäußerung vorgehen wir
alles getan wird und das offizielle
generativ dieses krieges um jeden preis
durchzusetzen jeglichen protest im keim
ersticken
das mutet ihr in der tat teilweise ihre
anne sie haben es gesagt die menschen
die einfach leere schilder in die höhe
halten und dann
festgenommen werden ist das auch zeichen
ausdrucks eines einer gewissen
planlosigkeit und
und
überreizung der ganzen situation oder
wie können sie sich das erklären die
hintergründe sind ist natürlich schwer
zu beurteilen das ist ganz klar das hier
ja wirklich
ein unglaubliches büro und abschreckungs
szenario aufgebaut wird auch also geht
hier sicherlich darum jeder person
deutlich zu machen was es für
konsequenzen mit sich bringen kann wenn
man sich gegen den krieg positioniert
wenn man wieder an diesem 18 er aktiv
widerspricht ist auch vielleicht ein
zeichen dafür dass die polizei selbst
auch wahnsinnig unter druck er ist nah
und lieber ich quasi jeden mitnimmt der
sich nur ansatzweise in dieses schema
passt und dann im zweifel vielleicht
freizulassen aber jedenfalls lieber zu
viel als zu wenig machen ist so ein
bisschen den eindruck den man da bekommt
ne wie ist es denn eigentlich wie geht
es denn dann weiter also in vielen
dieser fälle die werden ja nicht alle
jetzt über wochen oder monate
festgehalten sondern oft sind das ja so
festnahmen die für ein paar stunden die
leute auf die wache bringen und dann
auch wieder freilassen oder genau also
diese
auflösung der proteste auf die eg
festen hand dabei beobachten wir dass da
auch zwei anwendungen und übermäßiger
gewalt durch die zeit kommen das wären
videos infiziert die zeigen wie
friedlich protestierende schon der
polizei brutal mit schlagstöcken
geschlagen werden mit elektroschockern
betreut oder anderweitig misshandelt
werden und genau dann in gewahrsam
tatsächlich weitere
menschenrechtsverletzungen also
oftmals ist es wie sie gesagt haben die
personen werden
relativ schnell nach einigen stunden
freigelassen
aber was da in gewahrsam verfehlt also
in russland sind menschen die in haft
oder gewahrsam sind routinemäßig
schweren demütigung und andere
schaumweine handel ausgesetzt es gibt
berichte über folter und andere
misshandlungen von personen die eine
polizeistation festgehalten wurden wäre
auch aus mehreren städten berichteten
die darauf hindeuten dass personen unter
grausamen unmenschlichen und in den ring
guten bedingungen festgehalten wurden
viele menschen berichten dass sie keine
nahrung kein wasser keine
startmöglichkeit erhalten haben ja in
einigen städten auch in moskau wurde
berichtet in mehreren fällen das
anwältin der zugang zu den
festgenommenen verwehrt wurde also die
situation dann im
während der heute in gewahrsam
ja mit mit massiven
menschenrechtsverletzungen verbunden und
dann so dass in vielen fällen die
personen nach einigen stunden wieder
freigelassen werden natürlich werden
einige werden aber auch wegen
ordnungswidrigkeiten angeklagt und
müssen dann bis zu 30 tage haft und
geldstrafen aufnehmen zusätzlich wurde
am letzten märz gibt kann von
menschenrechtsverteidigerinnen soll aber
gar nicht daran den achtzigsten
geburtstag auf dem weg zu einer
mahnwache kurzzeitig festgenommen und
später wurde sie dann auf basis des
gesetzes für ordnungswidrigkeiten
angeklagt wegen des angeblichen
verstoßes gegen die regeln für
öffentliche versammlung ganz interessant
an diesem fall ist auch dass die polizei
erklärt hat das thema ganz china mit
hilfe von gesichtserkennung technik und
dem ausbau über ein identifiziert worden
sein soll solche fälle gibt es immer
wieder dass personen die an protesten
teilgenommen haben damit hilft schon
richtig herausgestellt
wie laufen denn dann diese verfahren ab
von denen sie da schon gesprochen haben
sind dass ich habe gelesen dass sind
quasi verfahren die haben wie am
fließband ablaufen wo also auch gar
keine argumente richtig ausgetauscht
werden sondern im grunde genommen nur
standardmäßig eine gewisse prozedur
durchgehechelt wird ist es muss man sich
das so vorstellen ja da muss man sich
das vorstellen
[Musik]
sehr kurz da manchmal keine fünf minuten
und und dann in der regel reine
formsache
also das ist das im bereich der
led worauf man aber sicherlich auch
wieder zunimmt den blick lenken sollte
was die gehören wir hören auch zu dem
strafverteidiger kein lebende und
organisatorin großer protest einleiten
das ist sie mir bei den chiefs protest
noch keine fälle bekannt von angeleitet
und straff aufwandes könnte aber in
zukunft lohnen zumal das auch im zuge
dieser
anfang mehr alpha franken eingeführten
gesetzesänderungen
drohen könnte anfang märz mehrere
änderungen im strafgesetzbuch von dem
gesetz über ordnungswidrigkeiten
vorgenommen unter anderem stehen jetzt
öffentliche handlungen die darauf
abzielen den einsatz der russischen
sprache zu diskreditieren unter strafe
das wird nicht erläutert was dann unter
dieser diskreditierung genau zu
verstehen ist und dieser waage bord hat
könnte zu politisch motivierter
verfolgung führen das haben wir in
anderen fällen immer wieder gesehen
dieses gesetz verbietet außerdem
ausdrücklich öffentliche aufrufe gegen
den einsatz der streitkräfte
ration kriminalisiert damit anti kriegs
proteste und das ist dieses an die
zensurgesetz entscheidung dieses gesetz
dass ich eben schon erwähnt habe nicht
das ist die gleiche materie fans genau
das sind in mehrere änderungen im
parlament kann man durch und
einzelpersonen können eben auch
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden wenn sie
innerhalb eines jahres bereits wegen
einer entsprechenden ordnungswidrigkeit
verurteilt worden sind das heißt also
unterstellen die jetzt vielleicht erst
wegen einer ordnungswidrigkeit
verurteilt werden den könnte dann im
nächsten schritt eine strafe drohen wenn
sie weiterhin protestieren und dann
würden hohe geldstrafen oder drei bis
fünf jahre haft oder andere sanktionen
also das ist ein warnschuss quasi hat
man ja und dann geht es aber tatsächlich
danach ans eingemachte
auch das lässt sich nicht so vorhersehen
also im fall der journalistin marina auf
safer die in den abendnachrichten
russische satz wir sind mit herrn stellt
gegen den krieg demonstriert darum wird
das ihr auch im strafraum gegen die
berichterstattung sie würden auch im
protestcamp genommen gehört hat
mindestens fünf stunden lang an von der
außenwelt dann sollen sie
medienberichten zufolge geben nach dem
ordnungswidrigkeitengesetz einer
geldstrafe verurteilt worden sein und
diesen russischen medienberichten aber
auch dass die behörden wohl eher werden
ein strafrechtliches
ermittlungsverfahren gegen sie
einzuleiten
da sieht man dass das dann immer noch
hinterher kommen kann quasi in basel
natürlich
wie gegen kamerun absehen kommen wir zum
schluss doch noch mal zu den sozialen
medien
auch da gibt es ja umfassende
einschränkungen die regierung die
regulierungsbehörde hat facebook und
instagram verboten das wurde jetzt
gerade durch ein gericht bestätigt
können sie ein bisschen dazu erzählen
welche rolle haben eigentlich soziale
medien in russland und ist dieses verbot
tatsächlich wirksam oder so löchrig wie
ich das inzwischen auch von vielerlei
seiten gehört habe
ganze ist natürlich teil dieser
bestrebung wirklich zieht im land zu
unterdrücken auf das wahre ausmaß des
leids und der zerstörung durch die
invasion zu verschleiern
und da teilte dessen ist eben auch
dieser sperrung der sozialen netzwerke
es gibt eben technischer sie sich
überhaupt verbindung und trotzdem in die
netzwerk einwählen können aber auch das
ist nicht immer zuverlässig und ist
natürlich etwas das auch uns alle leute
überhaupt technisch hinbekommen und
angesichts der willkür der russischen
gehören gibt es auch viele leute die
sich das gar nicht trauen wenn den
sperrung ist es ja nicht geblieben es
gab ja weitere repressalien gegen
medienhäusern ich war ganz genau also
kurz nach beginn der russischen
aggression um die behörden direkt
angeordnet den krieg nur noch als sonder
ein selbst der russischen streitkräfte
in der ukraine zu bezeichnen und
ausschließlich informationen aus
offiziellen russischen quellen zu
verwenden also begriffe wie krieg
invasionen angriff durch die zur
beschreibung der russischen militär
operation ende auch eine nicht verwendet
werden
anfang märz wurden außerdem neue gesetze
verabschiedet wie die verbreitung von
vermeintlichen falschinformationen und
die diskreditierung der russischen
streitkräfte zu bieten hier drohen hohe
geldstrafen und mehrere gehabt also im
falle der verbreitung angeblicher
falschinformation wie von den russischen
militäreinsatz sogar bis zu 15 jahre
mehrere medienhäuser sagen sich im zuge
dieser entwicklung in den letzten wochen
gezwungen ihre arbeit einzustellen
münchens 150 journalistinnen kann das
land aus angst vor italien verlassen wir
sehen hier so ganz klar ist die
russische
berichterstattung über den konflikt in
der ukraine zensiert und den menschen
sogar zu objektiven informationen
verwehrt unter anderem eben durch die
stellung von social media platz um und
der websites unabhängiger medien und
menschenrechtsorganisationen
gibt wirklich einen systematischen breit
angelegten angriff auf die volksfeste
und jegliche unabhängige
berichterstattung ich erschrecke absolut
erschreckend in der tat wenn man sich
jetzt mal zurück blickt auch nicht das
erste mal dass russland ein greift in
mit mediengesetzen versucht die
berichterstattung zu kanalisieren aber
so schlimm war es noch nie oder ja das
ist ein
sind sie denn eigentlich auch selber von
den repressalien betroffen
tatsächlich wurde auch große sprachige
webseite von amnesty international am
ende märz blockiert also im zuge dieser
vielen sperrungen diese da gesehen haben
die haben ja auch nicht nur eines die
betroffenen gesellschaft nicht
organisation
russische und internationale medien
darunter seiten gesperrt und natürlich
als als mannschafts organisationen auch
amnesty anteil dieser bescheiden dieser
sperrungen geworden mich würde
interessieren wie viele mitarbeiter
haben sie denn vor ort
aber ich hab noch welcher wir sprechen
natürlich nicht aus sicherheitsgründen
bei den aufnahmen
aus sicherheitsgründen sprechen wir
quasi nicht über den auftrittsort
unserer mitarbeiter
dann hoffen wir dass es auch weiterhin
gelingt ich danke sehr herzlich dass ich
die zeit genommen haben
so also das war der teil der sich jetzt
mit russland befasst und den prekären
wirklich zu herzen gehenden
menschenrechtsverletzungen dort und nun
blicken wir aber nach den haag wie wir
es ja schon vor zwei wochen getan haben
zusammen mit dem völkerrechtler claus
kreß ich darf noch mal verweisen auf
folge
201 so und da hat der ig jetzt
tatsächlich eine entscheidung verkündet
letzte woche pia was hat er gesagt er
hat gesagt sehr deutlich dass russland
alle militärischen operationen auf dem
staatsgebiet der ukraine unverzüglich
einstellen muss vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz wer es noch mal der eth der eth ist
das gericht der vereinten nationen und
streng zu unterscheiden vom
internationalen strafgerichtshof dazu
hat professor claus kreß auch wirklich
eine menge gesagt wir fassen uns also
heute kurz vor dem bgh geht es also
darum dass staaten gegeneinander klagen
in diesem fall also die ukraine die
russland verklagte es geht dann immer um
völkerrechtsverletzungen das
klitzekleine problem dabei ist
eigentlich das dgh überhaupt nur
zuständig ist wenn beide staaten quasi
mitglied in dem ich sag mal ag hag coop
sind oder sich zumindest den den regeln
des eba unterworfen haben das haben
weder die ukraine nach russland getan ja
dann hätte die sache auch schnell zu
ende sein können war es aber nicht im
gegenteil die ukraine hat nämlich
eigentlich ein ziemlich coolen
workaround gemacht also kann man
wirklich so sagen denn sowohl die
ukraine als auch russland sind parteien
der sogenannten völkermord konvention
und jetzt hat die ukraine aber nicht
etwa behauptet dass russland auf der
ukrainischen terror völkermord begehen
sondern sie hat sich darauf gestürzt wie
wladimir putin den angriff auf die
ukraine begründet hat denn der hat hier
vor dem angriff mehrfach behauptet
russland greifen der in der ukraine
quasi zur rettung ein weil in der
ukraine also genauer gesagt in der don
was region völkermord begangen werde und
die ukraine hat jetzt beantragt
festzustellen dass das nicht der fall
sei also sie hatten negativen
feststellungsantrag gestellt und die den
eil antrag auf einstellung der
feindseligkeiten
seitens der russen den hat sie quasi nur
hinten drangehängt und das verfahren na
ja da haben jetzt erstmal alle gesagt
das ist irgendwie relativ desaströse
also sehr kreativ aber relativ dieses
tritt losgegangen denn russland war dem
verfahren erstmal gar nicht erschienen
die sind nie mal aufgetreten aber sie
haben immerhin einen schriftsatz
eingereicht
also das war vielleicht auch schon
wirklich mehr als man erwarten konnte
nennen russland muss man ja
ehrlicherweise sagen sind ja was
völkerrechtliche dinge angeht ja das
blanke gegenteil von der ukraine die die
ukraine nimmt jetzt jeden strohhalm den
sie greifen kann auf den
unterschiedlichsten ebenen wie gesagt
das haben wir schon rauf und runter
besprochen und russland hat ja eine
tendenz wirklich schon seit jahren alle
völkerrechtlichen einwände hier vom
tisch zu wischen und so natürlich auch
diesmal haben aber immerhin ein
schriftsatz eingereicht und haben gesagt
na ja also eigentlich gehts ja gar nicht
um die völkermord konvention das ist ja
mal total konstruiert und sehr
interessant russland hat sogar
nachträglich selbst seine begründung für
diesen angriffskrieg verändert in dieser
schreiben also das ist schon wirklich
rallye wales denn dann dieses plötzlich
naja eigentlich haben wir das gar nicht
so gemein mit der völkermord mit dem
völkermord in der ukraine sondern wir
haben in ausübung unseres
selbstverteidigungsrecht kann
den ogh jetzt nicht so überzeugt nicht
ganz kurz noch mal dazu also warum wurde
russland dann angegriffen wahrscheinlich
die russische bevölkerung im donbass na
also in dieser region im osten der
ukraine oder genau die russischen
separatisten quasi ja dass da ein ein
völkermord stattfinde an der russischen
bevölkerung aber den ig hat das nicht
interessiert oder nie überzeugt genau
also weder die argumentation es gebe
einen völkermord in bonn was noch das
dass russland auch
selbstverteidigungsgruppen habe handeln
müssen hat der bgh überzeugt mit
immerhin 13 zu 2 stimmen also die
gegenstimmen waren ein russischer
richter und eine chinesische richterin
karabach kommt sozusagen
hat der ogh sich entschlossen diesen
kreativen weg der ukraine mitzugehen und
hat dem antrag stattgegeben und das
heißt der eth das muss man sich halt
auch mal überlegen sieht es ganz
offiziell als erwiesen an dass russland
sich auf den völkermord berufen hat und
damit haben sie gesagt damit haben wir
einen streit über einen gegenstand der
völkermord konvention und damit sind wir
zuständig so zu sagen wir haben noch
nicht mal stellung dazu genommen
zu dieser nachgeschobenen
selbstverteidigungs argumentation
russlands also das war denen
offensichtlich nur nicht mal eine
stellungnahme wert ist natürlich auch
schon irgendeine aussage und der eth
stellt dann fest dass die ukraine zur
durchsetzung der völkermord konvention
keinen militärischen operationen
unterzogen werden darf und das sind
dieses recht der ukraine natürlich
erheblich geschädigt wird das natürlich
typisches juristendeutsch durch die
militärischen handlungen der russen
nun muss man ja ehrlicherweise sagen das
hat vor allen dingen symbolcharakter
denn russland ist dadurch natürlich
wenig beeindruckt ist ja nicht so als
wenn jetzt ihre truppen zurückziehen nie
genau also und das hat durchaus auch
ganz gute rechtliche gründe denn der
ikea hat jetzt keine eigenen
vollstreckungsbehörde oder so sondern
wenn er seine eigenen entscheidungen
umsetzen will dann braucht er dazu den
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen un
das haben vermutlich wirklich jetzt
schon alle in den vergangenen wochen
gehört dort braucht man einstimmige
entscheidungen und da hat russland ein
vetorecht natürlich braucht man das gar
nicht zu versuchen denn dieses vetorecht
würden die russen ziehen die russen
haben auch sofort gesagt ich zitiere den
kreml sprecher dimitri peskow wir können
ein rücksicht auf diese entscheidung
nehmen und habe dann gesagt am
internationalen gerichtshof gibt es das
konzept des einvernehmens zwischen den
parteien hier kann es keinerlei ein von
ihnen geben punkt so also russland hat
im prinzip schon gesagt das ist uns
total egal trotzdem ist diese
entscheidung natürlich super wichtig
denn das ist ein wirklich deutliche
signal im prinzip an die ganze welt dass
auch das wichtigste völkerrechtliche
gericht der welt den angriff russlands
auf die ukraine nicht für gerechtfertigt
hält und dass sie dieses angebliche
selbstverteidigungs argument nicht mal
geprüft haben das lässt halt auch schon
tief blicken und es ist jetzt wirklich
ganz offiziell dass diese
fadenscheinigen rechtfertigungsversuche
des russischen präsidenten für diesen
für diesen angriff schlicht
nichts wert sind einfach gar nichts und
ich finde ganz unabhängig von der
entscheidung des bgh muss man ja auch
schon mal sagen dass die russische
regierung sich mit diesem schriftsatz
mit dieser ich sag mal ausgetauscht
begründung für einen angriffskrieg
selbst völlig demontiert hat und daher
finde ich eigentlich dass es definitiv
ein urteil dass wir euch nochmal mit
bringen wollten auch wenn natürlich die
russen jetzt nicht deshalb ihre
kampfhandlungen einstellen
gut also herzlichen dank dafür
und damit kommen wir jetzt von ukraine
krieg mal wieder auf nationaler ebene
und zwar nach karlsruhe wo wieder mal
die afg geklappt hat und das gleich
zweimal corinna was war los genau es gab
tatsächlich mal wieder eine empfindliche
schlappe für die afg in einer für sie
sehr essentiellen politischen frage
nämlich in der frage wieviel ausgrenzung
ist eigentlich erlaubt also müssen sie
wie eine normale
oppositionspartei behandelt werden ja so
dass verlangen sie das möchten sie gerne
wie alle andern oder dürfen die anderen
parteien sie ausschließen wie sie es
eigentlich quasi seit einzug in das
parlament
getan haben das ging jetzt aber nicht um
die sitzordnung oder um die sitzordnung
gegen ist nicht wie kommst du darauf
weil das doch immer so ein riesenstreit
war wer muss denn jetzt eigentlich neben
die afg sitzen wie bei den kindern
richtig weh sondern es geht um die
essentielle frage des vize präsidenten
oder der vizepräsident
das ist ja etwas eine sehr
herausgehobene stellung die im grunde
genommen jeder fraktion auch zur
verfügung steht und seitdem die afg im
bundestag ist also seid 2017 hat sie
auch insgesamt sieben mal versucht einen
vize präsidenten wählen zu lassen und
ist jedes mal gescheiterte die anderen
parteien haben das immer rundweg
abgelehnt vor allen dingen weil die
kandidaten zur auswahl waren auch immer
sehr umstritten waren und man eigentlich
der afg nicht den raum bieten wollte
warum sie gerade eben nicht wie eine
normale partei zu machen denn das haben
viele der parteien schon sehr deutlich
gemacht denn mit dem vize präsidenten
posten verbindet sich ja durchaus auch
eine gewisse macht ja das ist nicht nur
eine rein repräsentative aufgabe sondern
im wechsel werden diese vize-präsidenten
führen auch quasi durch die sitzung
leiten die sitzung müssen halt
eingreifen die reedereien oder auch
abmahnungen erteilen also das ist im
grunde genommen die ausübung des
hausrechts die durch den vize
präsidenten oder die vize-präsidentin
passiert und der diese machtfülle wollte
man der afg eigentlich einfach nicht
zugestehen das ist sozusagen der
hintergrund des ganzen so und die fdp
stimmt dass derartig stinkt das
natürlich schon seit langem sie hatten
natürlich immer auch versucht da
politisch darauf hin zu wirken hat das
schon lange lange beklagt und ging
schließlich auch nach karlsruhe das ist
also ein streit der den bundestag und
die justiz schon seit jahren beschäftigt
aber vielleicht noch einmal dazu wie
läuft das denn dann ab so eine wahl also
das heißt sie haben dann immer im ersten
zweiten dritten wahlgang einfach nicht
die nötigen stimmen bekommen haben sich
aus allen fraktionen sie die leute
geweigert afd kandidatinnen oder
kandidaten ihre stimme zu geben obwohl
das absolut willig usus ist nun
genau also normalerweise ich mein auch
die linke zb hat selbstverständlich
schon immer einen vize-präsidenten oder
auch eine vize-präsidentin ja also ich
werde auch ein kontrapunkt zum beispiel
genauer die dieses amt innehatte das war
eigentlich usus dass man auch immer die
kandidaten der anderen parteien wählt
nur eben bei der afg hat das überhaupt
nicht funktioniert da haben sich die
anderen parteien schlicht geweigert so
und das wollte die afd nicht auf sich
sitzen lassen ist nach karlsruhe gang
und dieses verfahren ist gleich aus
mehreren gründen
relativ spannend und zwar hatte sowohl
die fdp-fraktion geklagt als auch der
afg abgeordnete fabian jacobi der war
nämlich mal wieder so ein richtiger
fuchs na der hat etwas ganz besonders
schlaues wehrhaft
genau und da ging es nämlich konkret um
die wahlen des bundestags präsidiums im
herbst 2009 10 da hatte jacobi die idee
einen taschenspielertrick anzuwenden so
wo das jedenfalls meine auch in den
medien jetzt so gezeichnet und ich finde
das eigentlich eine ganz gute
umschreibung dessen was da eigentlich
passiert ist nämlich hier war es dann
wieder so dass der jeweilige afg
kandidat kein nicht die erforderliche
mehrheit bekommen hat in den zwei
wahlgängen dann hat der afg abgeordnete
fabian jacobi einfach einen zweiten
kandidaten vorgeschlagen ja und wenn
dass diese konstellation vorhanden ist
also wenn zwei kandidaten aus einer
fraktion für einen posten zur verfügung
stehen dann reicht eben die einen
filmdreh niedergang also nicht beim
ersten wahlgang reicht sie dann genau
genommen hatte dann die hoffnung dass
das dann irgendwie hilft dass sie sich
da nun geht es immerhin zwei von uns
muss keiner gewählt werden
und das hieß aber das präsidium zurück
also namentlich übrigens petra pau die
linken abgeordnete die den vorsitz in
dieser sitzung hatte hat das rundweg
abgelehnt hab das gar nicht erst
zugelassen hat gesagt einzelne
abgeordnete habe ich haben hier schon
gar kein vorschlagsrecht
und auch diese frage war eben eine mit
der sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht beschäftigen
musste in diesem komplexen fall
vielleicht nochmal zu dem argument was
sowohl die fdp als auch der abgeordnete
da ins feld geführt haben die haben
gesagt na ja also wir haben ja hier nun
folgende situation § 2 der
geschäftsordnung des bundestages gewährt
eigentlich allen fraktionen das recht im
präsidium vertreten zu sein das steht
eben auch explizit drin jede fraktion
ist durch mindestens einen
vize-präsidenten im präsidium vertreten
und darauf beruft sich natürlich die afg
ist ja auch erstmal plausibel genau das
muss man ehrlicherweise auch so sagen so
klingt das in der tat auch und die frage
war dann was ist denn eigentlich mit dem
zweiten teil denn da steht genauso
explizit drin das ganze muss durch eine
wahl erfolgen und deswegen war immer die
frage
wie es welche anforderungen sind an so
eine wahl zu stellen muss das ganze
verfahren so gestaltet sein dass auch
quasi das ziel erreichbar ist also muss
es quasi zwingend sein dass wirklich
jeder jede fraktion auch ihren viel zu
präsidenten stellen kann egal was die
anderen parteien sagen oder ist das
wirklich eine ernsthafte echte wahl und
da hatten sie dann eben verschiedene
argumente ins feld geführt die fdp
fraktion hat auf ein recht auf formal
gleiche mitwirkung an der
parlamentarischen willensbildung gepocht
und hat der artikel 38 absatz 1 satz 2
des grundgesetzes angeführt haben auch
gesagt es ist ein gibt ein recht auf
faire und loyaler anwendung der
geschäftsordnung ja vielleicht auch ganz
interessant sondern ein richtiges
argument
und sahen hier auch den grundsatz der
organen treuen verletzt und der
fdp-abgeordnete fabian jacoby hat sich
auch auf artikel 38 grundgesetz berufen
und da konkret auf das recht auf ein
freies mandat und das umfasse eben auch
das recht sich an den im parlament
anstehenden wahlen zu bezahlen ja es
auch durchaus ein eigenes
vorschlagsrecht dazu gehört zu bringen
können das jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
interessant aber gut was hat denn das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat zugesagt
das war einfach eine ziemlich deutliche
schlappe die klage der boa
fdp-bundestagsfraktion wiesen sie als
offensichtlich unbegründet zurück
übrigens dann auch das verfahren von
herrn jacobi und im grunde genommen ist
jetzt das kurze ergebnis die afg hat
eben keinen anspruch darauf ein vize
präsidenten des deutschen bundestags zu
stellen ja und zwar stellten sie da eben
ganz klar auf den begriff von wahlen ab
haben sich das also sehr genau angeguckt
haben auch so ein bisschen
demokratietheorie da ins feld geführt
dass vielleicht auch vor diesem aspekt
ganz interessant zu lesen diese
entscheidung nun haben ihm klar gestellt
mit einer freien wahl wäre es
unvereinbar wenn eine fraktion das recht
auf ein bestimmtes wahlergebnis hätte
denn das wäre es ja na also wenn man
sozusagen das ergebnis vorweg nimmt kann
man sich die wahl auch gleich sparen und
das ist einfach nicht das war wofür
wahlen eigentlich da sind die zeichnen
sich eben durch eine wahlfreiheit aus
und das muss eben auch die möglichkeit
geben den anderen parteien dass sie
dass sie eben auch leute ablehnen die
afg fraktion hatte jetzt aber gesagt na
ja aber dann die bis
bundesverfassungsgericht dann mach doch
zumindest mal wie prozedurale vorgaben
für diese wahl so dass wir da auch fair
behandelt werden hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht in wenig
überzeugt den gegner nicht sondern wir
haben einfach gesagt wir können uns
eigentlich nur darauf
beschränken zu gucken ob die wahl selber
fehlerhaft war ja aber darüber
hinausgehend gibt es keinerlei
gerichtliche kontrolle und deshalb gibt
es auch beim ergebnis keine gründungs
bedarf ja oder keine rechtfertigung
sondern das muss dann ihm so hingenommen
werden könnte eine fraktion einen
vize-präsidenten durchsetzen wäre die
wahl ihres sinns entleerten hat der
zweite senat gesagt sehr schön eine
typische bundesverfassungsgerichts
formulierung aber
durchaus nachvollziehbare entscheidung
was sagst du kurzum ein wort zu herrn
jacobi da hat eben das
bundesverfassungsgericht klar gemacht
hier ist es möglich dass die das
vorschlagsrecht eingeschränkt wird also
beschränkt wird darauf dass das nur
fraktionen machen dürfen und das ist
durchaus auch legitim und da ist auch
die begründung übrigens wieder sehr
hübsch und auch in klassischen duktus
des bundesverfassungsgerichts sind die
sagen nämlich das diene dazu um
interfraktionelle verständigung und
kompromiss potenziale zu erschließen ja
oder um es einfacher zu formulieren die
arbeitsfähigkeit des plenums zu
verbessern wisst ihr bescheid
genau also da kann man letztendlich
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen drüber
streiten ja weil ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob es so viel mehr
arbeit machen würde wenn jetzt auch die
einzelnen abgeordneten da ausnahmsweise
mal ein vorschlagsrecht hätten
letztendlich ist so ein bisschen das
ganze und jetzt vielleicht zu deiner
frage wie wird eigentlich finden
ja also ich diese entscheidung ist schon
absolut nachvollziehbar ich finde der
dass der kern des problems liegt
eigentlich in der formulierung der
geschäftsordnung die ja schon
auch in früheren zeiten ja einfach so
durchgegangen ist nicht da war das ja
usus dass jeder seine fragt jede
fraktion ihren vize präsidenten ihre
vierte präsidentin stellen konnte und
warum auch nicht ja also das sind ja
alles demokratisch
gewählte gewesen
und das ist jetzt nun in der afd anders
ist ist übrigens finde ich sehr misslich
also ich finde diese sonderrolle ist
grundsätzlich schon problem für das
parlament das darf man nicht anders
sagen ja also denn dass sie immer wieder
die möglichkeit hat sich selber auch in
die ecke zu stellen und zu sagen wir
werden hier ungerecht behandelt oder wir
werden hier anders behandelt ist
natürlich schwierig auf der anderen
seite wenn man mal beobachtet wie sich
die afd
im plenum verhält bei den bei den
debatten verhält wie schamlos da auch
wirklich
ja auch sprachlich und argumentativ
einfach
ins klo gegriffen wird mitunter das ist
schon
eine schwere belastungsprobe für das
parlament also in den debatten in den
zwischenrufen das muss man sagen dass
krieg kriegen vielleicht nicht viele
immer mit weil das nicht immer
thematisiert wird aber der ton ist schon
wirklich sehr viel rauer geworden
und dass die anderen parteien jetzt
sagen da wollen wir eben nicht dass sie
so eine zentrale funktion wie die des
vize präsidenten ausüben ist schon
nachvollziehbar denn da ist man quasi
der große dompteur der zampano in diesem
diskurs muss auch mal leute
rügen muss eingreifen in den button muss
eigentlich sich auch übrigens sehr
neutral verhalten genau ich glaube dass
das auch tatsächlich einer der punkte
ist denn was halt häufig vermisst wird
in der anführungszeichen argumentation
von fdp-abgeordneten ist natürlich die
sachlichkeit und die neutralität von
daher habe ich für das ergebnis auch
viel verständnis und ich habe auch viel
verständnis dafür dass man sozusagen dem
dem bundestag die freiheit lassen möchte
die eigenen gewohnheiten so zu steuern
aber es bleibt so ein bisschen so ein
rechtsstaatlich schwieriges gefühl ja
also das finde ich schon und dann sollte
man zumindest vielleicht sich überlegen
ob man die geschäftsordnung entsprechend
anpasst so dass es eben nicht einen
faktischen anspruch gibt er nur für eine
partei die eben demokratisch gewählt ist
eigentlich nie erfüllt das ist schon
schwieriger vielleicht noch mal als
letzten gedanken dazu dass
wahrscheinlich auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht da mal wieder
der falsche ort ist um solche dinge zu
klären das muss tatsächlich im parlament
geschehen richtig und dass hier das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht eingreift
und quasi einen vize-präsidenten kosten
verordnet ist vielleicht auch
nachvollziehbar gut aber das er so als
generelle
erklärung dafür und dann kommen wir
jetzt mal zum bundesgerichtshof
vor dem bundesgerichtshof ist jetzt der
reigen an urteilen zur corona krise
weiter gegangen da gab es jetzt wurde
eine sehr zentrale frage geklärt nämlich
die frage ob vom lockdown betroffene
betriebe anspruch auf schadensersatz
haben und haben sie die papiere haben
sie nicht null komma gar 0 also es ging
konkret nicht einfach nur spaß sondern
es ging um schadensersatz vom staat also
wir hatten ja schon hier entscheidungen
weil es auch immer irgendwie geld von
versicherern oder so darum ging es jetzt
nicht sondern es ging darum was quasi
der staat dafür haften dass der held die
betriebe reihenweise dicht gemacht hat
als wir alle im märz 2020 in den
lockdown mussten wir erinnern uns daher
alle leidvoll dran dann gab es überall
landes verordnungen so auch in
brandenburg da wurde eben auch ein
gastronom das sind wie immer gastronomen
die nahrung wie klagen auch erstaunlich
jedenfalls wurde ein gastronom dicht
gemacht also wir erinnern uns alle
gaststätten mussten schließen
touristinnen durften nicht mehr
übernachten und der hat dann auch nur
noch außer haus verkauf gemacht hat
allerdings auch sofort hilfen bekommen
von immerhin 60 000 euro er hat aber
gesagt na ja ich habe hier trotzdem noch
weitere massive umsatzeinbußen nämlich
genau 27.000 euro wollte er haben und
noch eine feststellung einer weiteren
ersatzpflicht des staates schon das
landgericht und das olg hamm gesagt
nichts gibt es und jetzt hat er auch vor
dem bgh verbunden und warum war es denn
so warum hat er keinen anspruch
die antwort ist wirklich denkbar einfach
aus juristischer sicht es gibt keine
anspruchsgrundlage
also es gibt entschädigungsregeln im
infektionsschutzgesetz unsere
regelmäßigen hörerinnen und hörer kennen
dieses gesetz ja wirklich mittlerweile
zur genüge vor allem den paragrafen 56
der gibt einen entschädigungsanspruch
gegen den staat wenn zum beispiel der
betrieb wieder auch hier geschehen auf
staatliche anordnung geschlossen wird
und die tätigkeit verboten wird so und
deswegen haben sich viele fuchsie unter
anderem auch anwälte gesagt mensch das
versuchen wir mal
er ist sich auch hören muss man ja sagen
also ich fand das im erlich gesagt nicht
wenn man in den paragraphen rein guckt
ja das ist schon klar aber so vom vom
rechtsgedanken her fand ich das
zumindest mal nach nachvollziehbar dass
man es probiert ne genau also die haben
sich vermutlich auch so ein bisschen den
klassischen es recht schluss
herangezogen und sich gedacht na ja wenn
es schon entschädigungen gibt für
konstellationen in denen der staat einen
störer heranzieht also ein betrieb von
dem eine gefahr ausgeht das regelt
nämlich quasi der 56 fsg dann müssen wir
ja wohl es recht geld bekommen wenn wir
überhaupt niemand gesteuert haben und
trotzdem dicht gemacht werden also
dieses klassische beispiel ist halt
irgendwie keine ahnung ein einen
bauernhof der geschlossen werden muss
weil die schweine die schweinegrippe
haben so ne und damit alles dicht
gemacht oder sony oder du hast
irgendwelche viren in deiner küche um
whatever und du ganz gezielt wirst
geschlossen von deinen staates und der
sagt dir du machst hirten so und das war
ja aber im corona lockdown anders und
genau so hat der bgh seine entscheidung
begründet und habe gesagt der staat hat
hier gerade nicht gezielt dieses hotel
dieses gastronomen dichtgemacht weil von
dem irgendwie eine ansteckungsgefahr
ausgegangen wäre oder was auch immer
sondern dieser mann war nur wie ganz
viele andere menschen auch als
sogenannter nicht störer als einer von
vielen also betroffen
und deswegen passt der 56 fsg nicht und
könnte man den aber vielleicht
verfassungskonformen auslegen haha da
hat der bgh ganz entzückend sogar noch
ganz aktuell eingearbeitet eine
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts vom vortag
also vom vergangenen mittwoch da hatte
das bundesverfassungsgericht nämlich
ebenfalls verfassungsbeschwerden
abgewiesen ebenfalls von hotel betreiben
denn gegen beschränkungen des
hotelbetriebs in der pandemie der hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt nee
also eure verfassungsbeschwerden sind
schon unzulässig ihr hättet vorher
erstmal die anderen gerichte also die
normalen instanzgerichte anrufen müssen
also rechtsweg nicht erschöpft wie wir
juristinnen sagen
und zwar hätten die dann auch erst mal
klären müssen ob diese
entschädigungsregelung aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz womöglich
verfassungskonform so ausgelegt werden
könnten dass die entschädigung auch für
lockdown fälle also hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist theoretisch
zumindest für möglich gehalten dass man
diese entschädigungsregelung aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz
verfassungskonform so auslegen könnte
dass die entschädigungen auch für die
allgemein kokona lockdown fälle ergeben
könnte der bgh hat das ganz klar
abgelehnt hat gesagt obwohl das
bundesverfassungsgericht das für möglich
hält lebt machen wir das nicht denn der
bgh sagt ich kann nur verfassungskonform
auslegen wenn mehrere deutungen einer
norm möglich sind und hier sagt der bgh
wir scheitern schon am klaren wortlaut
der norm der hat wirklich sehr deutlich
ab stellt so auf auf quasi eine
vorhandene gefahrenquelle die aus dem
betrieb kommt und das würde auch ein
verfassungskonformer auslegung wie das
halt so ausdehnt würde auch im
widerspruch zum einen deutlich
erkennbaren willen des gesetzgebers
stehen das ist natürlich auch dann auch
der grund dafür wenn man es genau so
sieht dann ist der rest eigentlich klar
wir wollten es aber trotzdem kurze
mitbringen weil der bgh dass sie echt
fast lehrbuchmäßig irgendwie durch prüft
und dann sagt deswegen gibt es auch
keine logar keine analoge anwendung der
vorschriften aus dem fsg weil ist
natürlich keine regelungslücke gibt
sondern die entschädigungsansprüche
gegen den staat sollten gerade ganz
ausdrücklich auf nur wenige fälle
beschränkt werden deswegen gibt es auch
keine staatshaftung über andere normen
also die prüfen das schon noch irgendwie
alles durch weil das
infektionsschutzgesetz hat das
einschlägige spezialgesetz ist deswegen
geht das vor ich kann also nicht ins
normale ordnungsrecht rein und mir da
irgendwelche anspruchsgrundlagen suchen
ich kann dich jetzt haftungs institutes
enteignen eingriffs haben gibt es
einfach nichts so hässliche dinge die
man prüfen können genau daran erinnert
man sich total ungerne wieder aber der
bgh hat sie alle an geprüft und gesagt
gibt es nicht gibt s nicht gibt's nicht
argument der gesetzgeber hat er gerade
das explizit nicht gewollt der hat nur
ein ganzen engen begrenzten fällen halt
wollt dass der staat haftet dafür dass
betriebe geschlossen werden und dann
sagt der bgh selbst in seiner
pressemitteilung schon sehr deutlich
hilfeleistungen für von der pandemie
schwer getroffene wirtschaftsbereiche
sind keine aufgabe der staatshaftung
belastungen auszugleichen die aus einem
von allen zu tragenden schicksal
resultieren dass nur zufällig einen
bestimmten personenkreis trifft ist
aufgabe des gesetzgebers
und dann sagt der bgh eben die hat der
gesetzgeber auch erfüllt diese aufgabe
der hat nämlich corona helfen zur
verfügung gestellt und nicht auf knapp
nicht zu genau richtig und deswegen ende
der durchsage corona hilfen gab es dann
gibt es nicht oben drauf oder quasi über
eine völlig andere schiene sagt
dass die natürlich im einzelfall auch
nicht dass abgedeckt haben was man
tatsächlich als schaden hatte das ist in
der tat bedauerlich das kann man hier
vielleicht auch mal an kennen aber das
ist eben auch keine vollkasko
situation muss man sagen so nötig und
ich meine gerade für die für die
gastronomen ist es glaube ich noch im
vergleich zu anderen berufsgruppen
extrem gut gelaufen die haben
tatsächlich so nachdem was ich so höre
relativ viele gelder bekommen da sind
jetzt andere berufsgruppen noch ganz
anders geschlagen gewesen und am ende
muss man ja halt schon sagen solange man
einigermassen irgendwie nachweisen
konnte dass man schäden hatte hat man ja
zumindest große teile der tatsächlich
entstandenen umsatzausfälle abzüglich
kosten und so weiter klar denn auch
wirklich bekommen und das ist natürlich
am ende ich sag mal aus aus sicht des
staates gesehen auch eine tragfähige
entscheidung denn ansonsten wären ja
jetzt ich weiß nicht wie viele
milliarden auf den deutschen staat dazu
bekommen ja das ist ja auch klar dass so
eine bgh entscheidung auf der anderen
seite auch führen für den konsequenzen
hätte haben können völlig unabhängig von
den konsequenzen der bgh hat nach dem zu
entscheiden was im gesetz steht und im
gesetz steht sehr deutlich drin das halt
so zu sagen man entschädigt wird wenn
man störer ist und deshalb der betrieb
geschlossen wird und nicht wenn alle
betriebe muss man einfach so ja insofern
in der tat du hast es schon angedeutet
keine besonders überraschende
entscheidung aber unbedingt eine die man
kennen sollte
[Musik]
wir bleiben noch mal kurz bei corona es
ist aber wirklich nur ganz kurz denn wir
haben ja uns weiß gott länglich letzte
woche damit beschäftigt und du hast ja
auch deutlich gemacht den hinweis
gegeben dass das mit den corona test mit
diesem kostenlosen bürgert es bald ein
ende haben könnte das haben wir schon
dafür als sehr bizarre entscheidung
empfunden und auch aber jetzt noch nicht
ganz so dolle bald wie man dachte genau
denn da hat der gesetzgeber tatsächlich
nachgebessert und hat gesagt die
sollten ursprünglich ende märz jetzt
auslaufen das wäre dann doch ein
bisschen knapp gewesen bei einer
inzidenz von 1700
plus
stattdessen wird das jetzt bis ende mai
angebotenes
bundesgesundheitsministerium arbeitet an
einer entsprechenden verordnung also das
könnte man sich vorstellen dass das in
den nächsten tagen hier noch durch geht
und dann gibt es noch länger kostenlose
bürger tests was natürlich auch total
sinnvoll ist in diesem zusammenhang und
dann hoffen wir ja dass der sommer da
ist und die zahlen nicht mehr
oder ehrlich gesagt dann sind
wahrscheinlich auch schon alle durch
gesorgt denn die dunkelziffer muss er
gigantomanische sein ja also ich meine
kennst du nicht sogar auch schon leute
die sagen ich gehe freiwillig in
quarantäne ich habe sowieso coruna und
die überhaupt keinen pcr test machen und
so weiter wird es nirgends an klar also
dass es berlin hierher in gang und gäbe
weil auch die der senat ganz klar sagt
wir haben einfach nicht genug pcr-test
wenn sie wenn sie einen positiven
schnelltests haben dann machen sie das
mal eigenverantwortlich ja und dann kann
man sich frühestens nach sieben tagen
frei testen und da sollten sich auch
alle daran halten
das wollen wir jetzt mal ganz stark
hoffen wir haben das schließlich einige
haben auch gemeinsam stellt euch mal
nicht so anders werden und dann kann man
sich auf einkommen reicht das jetzt mit
cola und also all das ist jetzt quasi
durch kann man kann man sagen vielleicht
noch ein hinweis auf diese bevor wir
gleich zum gerechten urteil kommen auch
vielleicht für die leute die uns noch
nicht so gut kennen wir haben
gleichzeitig übrigens auch ein produkt
des faz einspruch magazin ja das quasi
unser ja ich möchte fast sagen unser
mutter produkt ist und dafür das ist ein
kostenpflichtiges angebot im gegensatz
zu diesen podcast der natürlich
kostenlos zur verfügung steht aber weil
wir wissen dass ganz ganz viele davon
profitieren also persönlich inhaltlich
aber auch für das staatsexamen
hoffen wir auch immer dass leute ganz
fleißig ein abo abschließen für dieses
faz einspruch magazine hat man auch
zugriff auf alle auf das gesamte faz
online angebot und deswegen rufen wir
auch hier regelmäßig dazu auf bitte ein
abo abzuschließen jeder der mitmacht der
unterstützt auch diesen podcast so und
jetzt sind wir beim gerechten urteil
und was hast du uns denn mitgebracht
bier für das gericht orte diese woche
habe ich was aus meinem heimatland hier
mitgebracht quasi und zwar vom olg
düsseldorf
das hat nämlich entschieden dass achtung
ein geldautomat in ratingen ratingen
stehen bleiben darf jetzt erst mal nach
womit gerichte sich herumschlagen müssen
in diesem fall sogar oberlandesgerichte
aber das ist echt eine interessante
entscheidung fand ich weil sie hat auch
auf so ein aktuelles phänomen aufmerksam
macht dass jedenfalls mir gar nicht so
bekannt war und ich finde sie im
ergebnis sehr sehr grad es geht nämlich
um ein mehrfamilienhaus in ratingen das
ist eben hier in nordrhein westfalen bei
mir um die ecke quasi und in diesem
mehrfamilienhaus ist im erdgeschoss eine
bankfiliale es könnte man irgendwie
annehmen dass man sich freut dass es
überhaupt noch bankfilialen gibt aber
dass sie die miteigentümer dieses hauses
überhaupt gar nicht so sondern die
möchten dass dieser geldautomat da
entfernt wird warum also warum weil sie
angst haben dass dieser geldautomat
gesprengt
ja das ist in der tat ein verbreitetes
phänomen verbreiteter als man so denkt
das ist total crazy ich habe dann auch
mal angefangen das zu googeln dass man
manchmal kriegt es natürlich mit manni
ist dass ab und zu aber es ist
tatsächlich ein relativ verbreitetes
phänomen so der vergangenen jahre dass
täterinnen und täter geldautomaten
springen in anführungszeichen das ging
wohl erst mal an so quasi mit dem
klassischen camping gab es das haben die
da eingeleitet und dann von fern
angezündet und jetzt zunehmend weil das
wohl irgendwie eine höhere
fehleranfälligkeit hat ich wollte mich
jetzt auch irgendwie nicht ins bett
begeben das wahrscheinlich auch nicht
gut wenn ich dazu wie google jetzt würde
es auf jeden fall zunehmend mit
richtigem sprengstoff da haben sie so
und dann nehmen sie das geld aus dem
automaten
hauen sich auf ihre autos oder wohl sehr
beliebt auch motorräder und verschwinden
binnen minuten und das ist wohl ein
deutschlandweit durchaus verbreitetes
phänomen nach polizeiangaben aber
besonders verbreitet hier bei uns in
nordrhein westfalen das kommt wohl wird
quasi als ausweich kriminalität aus den
niederlanden da gibt es übrigens ein
wort das heißt ich kann leider kein
niederländisch aber ich finde dieses
wort unglaublich niedlich beauftragter
also die da hört es halt knacker quasi
das sind knall knacken die holländische
polizei diese menschen das war wohl eine
zeit lang wirklich hippies verbrechen
das hat total überhand genommen und der
hand haben die ermittler mittlerweile
richtig hochgerüstet also da gibt es
jetzt geld auszahlungen irgendwie nicht
mehr nach 23 uhr die automaten befinden
sich nur noch in geschlossenen räumen
werden extrem gut gesichert und so
weiter und je mehr die holländer und
holländerinnen quasi ihre
ermittlungsmaßnahmen hochgefahren haben
desto mehr sind wohl die täter nach
deutschland und vor allem hier nach
einer herzlichen gang genau vielen dank
auch
also wer hier das ist auch so ein
bisschen der klasse kann wer so
genannter autobahn wohnt der der macht
sich da jetzt irgendwie zunehmend sorgen
weil die leute dann natürlich bin
minuten wieder quasi in holland sind zum
ist auf der autobahn und dann ist man
hier gerade aus nrw natürlich ziemlich
fix wieder in holland und so manchen
anderen städten das sind wohl keine
richtigen banden aber es werden wohl
durchaus gemeinsame strukturen genutzt
nach angaben der polizei also ich hab
sogar ein einen artikel mit einer
polizeibehörde ich glaube es duisburg
gefunden wo dann schrieb irgendwie
würden sich nicht nur tatfahrzeuge
teilen sondern auch anwälte das war
nicht alles
habe ich jetzt mal nicht weiter
irgendwie verfolgt jedenfalls sind
deshalb enorme sachschäden die da
entstehen also ganz häufig ist es so
dass die sachschäden die entstehen bei
diesen automaten sprengungen viel viel
höher sind als das was diese täterin da
tatsächlich erbeuten die personenschäden
hingegen sind wir bislang sehr
überschaubar also da hat man es hat wohl
mal so fasst verletzungen gegeben aber
ich habe jetzt uns nichts dazu gefunden
das ist der wahnsinnige personen schenkt
aber jetzt haben natürlich natürlich
warum bist du denn der meinung dass wird
es wirklich so rabiat durchaus auch
vorgeht warum das dann in einem wohnhaus
in ordnung wäre wenn so ein ding steht
na ja also ich meine irgendwo müssen
bankautomaten jahr stehen aber nicht gut
aus warum denn nicht im wohnhaus also
ich meine dieses wohnhaus hatte das muss
man jetzt vielleicht mal dazu sagen
dieses wohnhaus hatte 1971 in einer in
der teilungserklärung der wohnungs
miteigentümer quasi steht schon drin
dass da eine bank im erdgeschoss sein
darf und genau dieses argument hat sich
jetzt auch sowohl das landgericht als
auch das oberlandesgericht geschnappt
also vielleicht ganz kurz die
miteigentümer die dann geklagt haben
haben jetzt herzlich gegen die bank
geklagt die da drin ist und wohl die
bank nur mieterin ist weil wohl der
vermieter also quasi der miteigentümer
hat nichts gemacht und dann das wohl ein
ehepaar die haben sich dann gedacht okay
jetzt klang mal direkt gegen die
santander bank und und klar verklagen
die darauf dass sie ihren automaten
wieder abbauen und die haben natürlich
gesagt na ja also ganz ehrlich wenn wir
irgendwie eine bankfiliale haben dann
ist es irgendwie normaler bestandteil
unserer bankkreisen dass wir auch einen
geldautomaten haben das ganze war jetzt
irgendwie gestützt auf 1004 bürgerliches
gesetzbuch unterlassungsanspruch aber
das olg düsseldorf hat jetzt gesagt gibt
es nicht und hat gesagt das
gemeinschaftseigentum wird durch
geldautomaten nicht beeinträchtigt 1971
hätten nämlich alle eigentümer in der
teilungserklärung zugestimmt dass im
erdgeschoss eine bank für die alle da
hat noch keiner gesprengt
wichtig damals gab es noch nicht mal
bankautomaten muss man allerdings hat
das
ja aber da hat allerdings das olg und
das finde ich auch durchaus tragfähig
gesagt na ja damals gab es ja in der
bank auch bargeld hinter der theke hätte
man ja auch irgendwie ein raubüberfall
begehen können und das ist jetzt
natürlich sehr formalistisch aber da
sagt dass ihr gehalt auch änderungen der
uns regeln dieses hauses könnten die
eigentümer nur einstimmig beschließen
die sind halt nicht einstimmig war
offensichtlich der vermieter dieter
santander bank filiale war keine lust
drauf hat so und jetzt hat das olg aber
schon auch noch gesagt das aufstellen
und der betrieb dieses geldautomaten
seien noch sozialer denn das sei halt
nur bei juristen wurden erstmalig auch
sehr die bloß abstrakte gefahr eines
zugriffs versuchs reicht halt nicht und
der mieterin die ihr genehmigte nutzung
zu untersagen
und das finde ich wirklich super
tragfähig das gericht hat gesagt es gibt
keinerlei konkrete hinweise darauf dass
hier dieser konkrete geldautomat
gesprengt werden soll und dann haben sie
sich da auch noch immer zahlen an den
kopf geschmissen das gericht hat dann
gesagt hier gibt es ungefähr 70.000
geldautomaten bundesweit und 350
sprengen ja und dann haben die eheleute
gesagt ja aber das waren die zahlen aus
2008 sehen und dann ging das irgend so
ein bisschen hin und her alles relativ
lustig jedenfalls sagt das rki auch wenn
es die zahlen aus 2021 nahelegen dass
das risiko einer sprengung bei 0,65
prozent läge reicht ihnen das definitiv
nicht aus und da wirklich irgendeine
konkrete gefahren zu nehmen und sagen
das ist im prinzip eine latente gefahr
und man kann nicht jeder laterne war aus
weg gehen das ist jetzt sozialadäquat ob
ich wirklich total fair denn es ist mein
ich kann nicht auf der einen seite sagen
bankfiliale im haus finde ich super und
dann sage ich irgendwo eine bankfiliale
das ist so ein bisschen wie wir nicht
über eine kneipe ziehen und dann sagen
mensch ist es laut hiergegen haben soll
weg und am ende kann man halt auch nicht
jedes potenzielle risiko im leben
ausschließen ich habe mich auch nicht
beschweren wenn ich rausgehe auf die
straße und dann über fährt mich jemand
dann kann ich auch nicht sagen ich
möchte jetzt weil das passieren könnte
alle autos von der straße verbannt also
ich meine so ein gewisses leben diese
art von argumentationen wird ja durchaus
auch geführt aber ich gebe dir recht
also mit anderen worten sagt das gericht
nichts anderes als seid nicht so
hysterisch kann man vielleicht passieren
sehr sehr nett formuliert ich habe mir
wirklich noch das urteil schicken lassen
und so das ist alles total nett bringen
wir haben auch ganz viel verständnis für
diese ängste und so aber irgendwelche
abstrakten ängste wenn es überhaupt
keine konkreten gefahren gibt reichen
jetzt nicht um die mieterin die nutzung
zu untersagen die man ja eigentlich
expliziten hat und das finde ich ok das
dem würde ich mich anschließen dann ist
das also unsere gemeinden
gerechte urteil der woche damit dieser
rubrik wollen wir deutlich machen dass
justiz auch sehr sehr viel mit
gerechtigkeit zu tun hat auch wenn es
viele immer wieder bezweifeln aber so
ist das also ich hier das ist unser
kleiner werbeblock für die justiz und
allerdings möchte ich dazu sagen dass
wir auch manchmal ungerecht wurde ja und
sie explizit als solche oder vielleicht
auch manchmal nicht einer meinung sind
was jetzt die gerechtigkeit eines
urteils angeht und auch hier und da auch
hier gibt es natürlich die möglichkeit
dass leute das anders sehen und da
bieten wir natürlich immer wie steht's
um
rückmeldungen auf wir freuen uns über
feedback ich muss als kleinen disclaimer
sagen ich bin in der letzten woche etwas
rückständig geworden was jetzt hier die
beantwortung der leser anfragen oder
hinweise aber auch recht vielen
es läuft einiges auf und dann war ich
letzte woche nicht hundertprozentig
präsent würde jetzt mal sagen gedanklich
und
deswegen entschuldige ich mich aber ich
sage gleichzeitig wir freuen uns
weiterhin über feedback bitte bitte
weiter schreiben unter einspruch podcast
etwas faz.de dass es uns immer lieb und
teuer denn da nur so werden wir besser
indem wir von ihnen in dem mir von euch
hören man kann auch auf unserer webseite
gehen oder über twitter und anschreiben
da sind wir auch natürlich präsent also
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
hat sich in deinen dir in die vip aber
wie jede woche habt eine gute woche
passt auf schöneres woche tun
[Musik]